morning so we'll go up well okay ahead
and get started
I'm Brian Rivera I'm a graduate student
at the University of Alabama
I'm in in the educational psychology
ph.d program
there's also I'm also in the educational
neuroscience concentration so I spend a
lot of time thinking about how people
learn math and how we understand math
from like how children develop math
understanding - like how
adults do it so I'll be talking about
how to do online experiments using the
Wolfram language I worked in this
project this past summer at the Wolfram
summer school
yes so we'll go ahead and get started
I'll tell you a little bit about sort of
like experimental psychology and why I
believe some of those experiments can be
moved from online there's people already
doing this type of research in what are
called massive online experiments or
most I'll mention some of the
technologies that are used for running
these types of experiments I'll talk
about my project and then some of the
other possible applications for for that
particular use of the Wolfram technology
so we have been interested in measuring
behavior since the beginning of of the
20th century goes back to Bill him went
and in this lab trying to measure
reaction time and the those sorts of
experiments have consisted of of
comparing two different groups and it's
a ratio of between group differences
over within within group differences and
and given that structure the more
participants that you have on an
experiment the better your
signal-to-noise ratio is going to be but
this is an inherently biased approach in
that you end up testing all the people
that are close to into your lab so
that's geographic limitation in terms of
who you get to test who you get to bring
to the lab and this is something that we
have inherited in psychology and in
experiments today as you might know a
lot of the experiments that we that we
conduct are conducted in undergraduate
students and either at the US or or
you European country so that we have
inherited some of those problems but I
think that with the increase in in
reliance off of technology and and how
laptops have been reliable to run all
sorts of experiments it has has allowed
to sort of like shorten that that gap in
terms of of who we get to test and in
how and and I think that it's the the
this possible and accept is moving on
some of this experiments online and
being able to test different populations
through the use of the Internet and this
is essentially the concept behind
massive online experiments so people
there's there's a literature now on
people doing those those types of of
experiments in and for it to be massive
it consists of on the upwards of 50,000
participants so there's this are
master groups of people that are being
tested and some type of cognitive or
psychological assessment it can be
something very simple that can that can
be run online but this makes it yosh
it's a short and easy way to carry out
these experiments it's also way cheaper
than bring in participants to the to the
lab and it allows to cross demographic
and international and in countrywide
boundaries in that you can set up an
experiment online and have participants
all over the world come in and be tested
and in some of those and some of those
metrics it also allows for more
statistically powerful comparisons so
the more participants you have the the
more powerful your your your powers
which is the ability to find a
difference there where they're what
there is one it also allows for for
experiments to be shorter so if I if for
an experiment I required six hundred
trials I can either have ten subjects do
six hundred trials of a specific task or
have a hundred subjects do sixty trials
and I'll get a better oh I'll have those
hundred subjects have completed a
shorter experiments I mentioned already
the benefit of having higher power and
this is not just
sort of like a nice way of doing this
type of science or doing this type of
assessment this is the way that that we
would want to do science if we wanna
want to make sure that the findings in
cognitive science in psychology are
generalizable to the overall population
we would want you know we want to have
power behind a claim and not be based on
a couple of subject subjects that are
based on at the university but it does
bring some limitations that I'm sure
everybody singing your mind said so
through online experiments how will you
control for a lot of the variations that
I merchant in and trying to
psychologically test someone or
experimentally test someone so those are
their inherent limitations on how do you
control the luminance of the screen the
time of the day that someone is doing
something that background how do you
control for the background of a
participant might have or might not have
and those are inherent problems that um
that there's better ways to to be able
to account for them or not but uh
there's there's still problems in there
the the other problem is that in
psychology for everyone here or some
people here it might not be you know a
stretch to say that they would be able
to program an experiment set up a
database where they can host sort of
like the data in dual source of computer
savvy things but in psychology it that
might not be feasible for one person or
they might not have the how do excuse me
the out the knowledge of how to go about
doing that so that that puts a limit of
people being able to make use of this of
this technology and it does take a lot
of technological knowledge knowledge and
being able to to conduct an experiment
like like this so what are the tools
that are that are useful for the current
experiments that have been published
what sort of tools are are used one of
the the most common ones is for for
psychology labs or cognitive science lab
to set up their to set up an entire
experiment in their own website and they
completely take care of all of that
having people from computer science sort
of aid them in that in that enterprise
so they don't really have to
release or share they're so big
technological knowledge but all their
people have sort of been developing some
something knowledge is to be able to
create a community of people doing
online online experiments so one of them
is Sergei's psych run by Josh to live
and basilar college and it enjoys this
small community of users people that
have been publishing using that platform
there so there are some publications
like I mentioned for but for psychology
people or people in in education I sit
the case for me educational psychology
we might not have this the knowledge of
JavaScript and HTML and they know how to
how to be able to set up set up that the
the other limitation is that this
particular software is a client-side
library so something that would run on a
participant's laptop and at the end of
the experiment that would have to send
the data sort of back to back to the
experimenter and and also in terms of if
there's problems with with the software
it is mostly run but this but this one
person so there's there's pros and cons
in terms of using this the seller put
but it has been use in and there's
reasons to be excited about that
software at the em I will say a more
prevalent one is the use of Amazon
Mechanical Turk I don't know if you guys
are familiar of I've heard of this way
of conducting experiments but it's sort
of popular and the idea behind it is
that there's this platform with an
Amazon with within Amazon that allows
people to submit hits or specific my new
jobs that you can set up in someone
somewhere in the in the world will be
able to solve that specific problem or
solve the specific test it could be
something like you submit copies of
receipts and someone has to make sure
that the number and they receipt is what
what some software calculator or be able
to make something very very
straightforward but that you would need
sort of like human power to be able to
solve
so that's platform offers the ability of
pain
people essentially for it for take going
on their completing an experiment so you
can have 600 trials of a comparison of
two different stimuli you can measure
reaction time behind it sort of like
behind the screen and a participant can
go in there and complete 600 trials
the benefit of it is that it is usually
pretty fast so if I were to set up an
experiment earlier in the day but the
end of the day I would have you know
thousand people that have completed my
my experiments so that's the benefit
sort of like for being speeding in terms
of being able to complete an experiment
there's many publications that have that
rely on Mechanical Turk the on the con
side the platform itself is not designed
to conduct experiments so it makes it
really hard to counterbalance in and do
sort of like the the more scientific
rigorous rigorous way of conducting the
experiment it requires three types of
languages again for some of them might
not have this there's background it
might be difficult yes you could you
could do that as well
yes the platform is for for all sorts of
things there but my point is to that
there's some psychologists going in
there or experimental psychology is
going in there using this platform to to
do some of the assessments that I'm
interested in that nobody we're
interested in and the the the population
of the the the only this online labor
market is mostly based in the US in
India so it's better than typical
undergrad populations but still not very
presentative of well what we would what
we would want so wolfram out the full
Wolfram language offers this pre-cool
capability of having a running an entire
experiment within the same the same
language so you can program deploy
online run run in the cloud collected
data
get the data on a wolfram notebook and
conduct analysis what's in the same
within the same language so it's easier
to learn and it was possible for one
person like me to be able to develop to
use this technology and apply it within
a couple weeks it within a couple of
months so it doing science this way
enjoys the the support would enjoy the
support of all the people there using
the Wolfram language so that be able to
learn new things about how to display
stimulus and how to go about structuring
and experiment and to my knowledge
there's not a lot of people doing this
type of assessment so that's an
advantage of being a pioneer and not
everyone's doing it but that's also a
disadvantage that I have no idea what
I'm doing and just setting that online
so there's no standards yet as to how to
go about doing science using the the
Wolfram language so I'll tell you a
little bit about my project that is the
same disclaimer that this just was my my
project and to the degree that this is
my show skill or the lack of skill in
terms of how to go about conduct an
experiment it will be my my own fault I
only started using the Wolfram language
this this year so I'm fairly new and I
was able to pick it up this summer and
apply it to something that I was
interested in which is sort of like
there's numerical cognition testing here
so I programmed this experiment and it
runs some on the cloud and this is what
what it looks like so there's some
instructions and something very simple
it's basically there's going to be a
fraction percentage with a zero zero or
a one on the bottom and in the
participant would have to press or the
diffraction the numerical value of the
fraction is closer to zero or one so
I'll show you what it looks like at the
beginning there are some calibration
trials so to get some basic measurements
of how long it takes to click either 0
or 1 now there are some errors because
it's not connecting to my data drop all
right let's see a thing I have 5
yes it'll be something like that zero
one so it's something very simple it's a
very simple trial we're able to capture
reaction time in the background and
you'll be able to save the information
in terms of the numerator denominator
and some other information about that
specific that specific Charles so that's
what it looks like for this particular
setup I have I think 200 trials which
will take about you know five to seven
five to seven minutes on dia on the
backend so in the main skeleton this is
where I'm I exhibit my lack of knowledge
of the Wolfram language ambien a dynamic
module module which is basically
displaying specific stimulus up to the
point that a button is pressed and then
when a button is pressed displaying a
sort of like just having a simple
counter of like the number of trials in
this place sort of like a rounded
numerator a random denominator a button
is pressed in this place on you a new
stimuli and that keeps a counter after
two hundred trials once the buttons
press sort of like it exits out of that
and that's that's something very simple
that I was able to to do right away
there might be better ways or more
particular ways to get at this
particular structure but sort of like
this is what I what I went with
if you're interested in looking at the
the code it's all in the on the notebook
that has been submitted to passable I
won't go into detail of that here in
terms of the data within the code
there's the structure for for it to
create data been in and depending on how
familiar you are with the Wolfram data
drop so it's basically sort of this this
additional technology that exists within
within your Wolfram account that allows
you to collect data for any type of
device or any type of
of program and in this in this case what
I'm what I'm simply doing is that once
there's a bottom click in that
particular trial that button clicks
drops the data that I want and saves it
to this online online platform to one of
these one of these bins and in here and
if you can of you can see so this is
what the website looks like and this is
sort of what the the data will look like
so it saves the response either well as
zero or one the time submitted and in
terms of excuse me in terms of time it
the course up to the millisecond so you
will be able to get fine-grained
recording of when it was press so that
allows you to to then calculate reaction
time the numerator denominator some of
the the ID of the computer in terms of
if there were two people doing it at the
same time you can use this ID to to see
whose trial that that trial it belongs
to and stimulus presentation so it would
save for it for an experiment at is for
example 600 trials you would have 600
data points so like like this so again
the type of analysis that I have it can
easily access it within with a notebook
with a couple of wines you import that
data from your wool from data drop
profile and you can start doing analysis
within within a notebook so in here
again if you're interested in the coal
of calculating reaction time in
calculating the magnitude its own on the
the notebook but I'll move to the to the
end here so I was basically took that
data in plotted in terms of the
magnitude so I'd only showed fractions
from from 0 to 1 and I plotted that on
the x-axis and then reaction time in
seconds on the y-axis so that you get
sort of like this nice the distribution
of of the reaction time depending on
different on different magnitudes and
then I showed the accuracy in terms of
this contrast from blue to yellow and
you can see that most incorrect trials
at least for this was
simply a couple of pilot participants I
haven't got enough irb-approved
to be able to deploy this - and you want
to be able to use that that data but
simply on a couple of people that I was
able to test it with sort of like shows
this cluster of incorrect trials
centering around half which is sort of
what what you can expect in terms of
like a fracture like one over a hundred
is very easy to distinguish close to
zero and something like 100 over 100
will be very easy to distinguish that is
that is one but include in terms of like
43 over 47 it might be harder to to
judge so that's the source of things
that are you will be able to tell with
these types of experiments something
that I will be interested in so that's
basically it in terms of the of the
experiment for all their applications
I'm more excited about the possible uses
of this type of of this type of
technology and that being able to adapt
it in other ways not necessarily
experiments or not necessarily to
collect behavioral data but in terms of
something like doing a live poll being
able to program something and you share
at the beginning of of a talk and then
people being able to respond right away
running that on a notebook and being
seen a figure updated in real time to
collect sort of like that that knowledge
surveys can be done easily and in
something more exciting and in terms of
having for example a teacher being able
to develop a type of assessment sharing
that with with students and being able
to get that that data without sort of
like going into details about the
programming all using the the Wolfram
language and being able to deploy that
deployed that online so that's all I
have so I will take questions now
you
[Applause]